a lot of people don't give themselves
permission to actually start
implementing until they feel like they
have complete information but you only
get complete information after you start
doing it and so it's a logical fallacy
and so people just believe the fallacy
because it's safer you feel like you're
being successful when you continue to
learn and read but you'll learn a hell
of a lot more about sales in your first
10 conversations about sales than all
the books you've put together now here's
an interesting one once you have done a
certain amount of something then if you
read something you'll have context
because it's very difficult to learn
something when you don't have a lattice
work to hang it on oh yeah I did do that
oh I could have done that differently
but if you're doing it against an
amorphous like maybe someday I will I
don't even think you really learn it